so people often ask me you know why i am
so stubborn and hard-headed and
close-minded refusing to admit when i'm
wrong refusing to apologize doubling
down when people are upset at me and
then tripling down when they're mad that
i doubled down the answer is that i'm
just kind of a jerk frankly i mean
that's the answer but also because
although maybe not everyone can or
should operate this way we all have
different personalities
some of us need to
because this is the kind of thing we're
up against
we cannot all be
equivocators and compromisers while we
face an ideological opponent who stands
firm in his position no matter what
regardless of the facts regardless of
anything
some of us have to be a bit obstinate
headstrong or else we'll all be blown
around by the breeze like little leaves
and twigs
a perfect example of the left
stubbornness which uh calls for for a
proportional response i think is this
it's been less than a week since the
justice millett verdict when the left
and the media were
all you would think humiliated after the
hoax they promoted was revealed as a
hoax
you might assume that they would want to
crawl into a hole for a while lick their
wounds hide their faces
and certainly steer plenty clear of
anything else that looks like it might
be a race hoax but that's just not how
they roll and so yesterday espn with
timing that is not a coincidence
decided to air a special on the bubba
wallace story
now you remember that bubba wallace was
the black nascar driver who claimed that
somebody hung a noose in his garage last
year
nascar rallied around him the media ate
the story up and it all culminated in
the dramatic display of all of the
drivers of talladega marching around the
track with bubba wallace in a show of
solidarity and they all gave him hugs
and they were all crying
of course there's one really important
detail about that noose quote unquote
which is that it was not a noose
it was a rope that you used to close the
garage door a garage door pull as you
know we call it
anyone who's ever been in a garage might
be familiar with these contraptions
they're just like ropes right that's why
they're hanging that's why it's
interestingly enough hanging from the
garage door you might wonder oh why is
that rope on the garage door oh because
when you pull it the the door goes down
wow
nascar drivers who spend many hours in
garages are certainly familiar with with
these things they see them all the time
but even if bubba wallace and everybody
else at the speedway that day had
suffered amnesia and forgotten about the
existence of garage door pulls
they still could have easily figured out
whether the rope was meant to be some
kind of racist message to bubba wallace
there there are security cameras all
over the place
as some of us pointed out when this
story was first reported
well there are security cameras so
couldn't you just
quite easy to find out what's going on
simply go back and check the footage and
see how long the rope has been there if
it's been there for longer than a day or
two that means that it could not have
been targeted at bubba at bubbles
malette bubba wallace sorry because
nobody would have known prior to that
point that wallace would be assigned to
that garage
so that's all you got to do
security cameras just look at them look
at the footage it'd take like 10 minutes
now as it happens the fbi showed up with
15 agents to investigate the rope
and they did exactly that they checked
the tape and when they did they
discovered that it had been there since
the previous year
for months it had been hanging there and
nobody thought anything of it
did we need 15 fbi agents to look at the
footage and discover this is there a
reason why nascar couldn't have done
this themselves immediately before
running out to the public and telling
everyone that there's a suspected
potential noose-like structure in
bubba's garage
the answer to both is no
well the real answer is no they didn't
need the fbi agents they could have
checked themselves but they preferred
the narrative of the racist noose and so
they ran with it until they could run no
longer
or you thought they could run no longer
but here they were last night on espn
trotting this thing out again a year
later
let's watch some of this clip here
i just wanted to stand with him during
the national anthem to show my support
for him
and was appalled by
what i had learned
and then as drivers got involved i think
crew members team managers team owners
it really started to snowball within a
very short period of time
[Music]
the most
incredible
non-competitive moment in sports i'd
ever seen
that moment i could feel the weight of
that moment and and i think we all did
as we were walking
yes it may have been
one of the most incredible moments in
sports never in history never the
history of sports has there been such
pageantry and emotion surrounding a
garage door
this was quite easily i think we could
say this right
quite easily the most dramatic garage
door related sports moment in world
history
but i'm not sure if that's anything to
brag about necessarily
and just because i'm a glutton for
punishment let's keep watching a little
bit of this clip here
i
get out of the car
i look back
and i was like holy sh it's a whole
garage
the whole garage
that's when i lost it
in the midst of all the turmoil
that was going on in the world
with the black and white the hatred and
everything that was going on
the entire nascar family
rallied behind my son
[Music]
very inspiring um now just to remind you
you know again
it was not a news
so it was 100 not any kind of racist
attack at all
it was just a rope with a loop on it so
you could grab hold of it to pull the
door closed
um and and by the way that's also how we
know it's not a noose
because a noose and i know like this
people on the left
uh they don't spend a lot of time
outdoors they probably don't do a lot of
fishing or you know that kind of thing
so
um they're not familiar with tying knots
but i can tell you that not every knot
is a noose
in fact most of them aren't only one
knot is a noose and it's a noose and all
the others are different kinds of knots
and but they might look kind of similar
because i know again
if you don't spend a lot of time outside
you and you maybe and all you do is
watch corporate media you see a rope
and maybe you just start breaking down
in tears because you think well why else
would that rope be there except to hang
somebody
uh but a new system has a particular
application and so one of the like by
definition a noose when you pull on the
loop
it constricts
because that's that's why that's what
it's made to do that's what makes it a
new so if you pull on the loop and it
does not constrict then it's not a noose
and so since this thing was hanging
there as a garage door for since since
the previous october we could probably
assume that it was not constricting when
you pulled on it because i mean like
every time you try to shut the garage
door it would break your hand
and so i'm going to assume that that had
not been there for months where every
time you uh you shut the garage door
just everyone's getting their hand
broken and no one thinks to change the
knot so i'm assuming that's not the case
which means that it was just a it was a
knot that did not constrict it's not a
news
so this in other words this was not a
makeshift gallows that had been set up
to perform executions before uh you know
before the race
we know all of this now i mean any
intelligent person knew at the moment
they heard about the story even before
the fbi brain trust confirmed it but now
even the dumbest among us knows it
and still espn aired the special
they report they reported themselves
last year that the fbi confirmed it was
not a hate crime and yet here they are
you thought the media would be
embarrassed by jesse smellette instead
they're saying oh yeah you think we're
embarrassed by that we'll take this
here's an emotional documentary about a
black guy who was afraid of his garage
door
so this is the this is the double down
it's also as i've been explaining for
the last few weeks the reality curation
they are shaping the way people view
reality
the actual details don't matter
in fact in fact the whole idea that
nooses are racist symbols
is itself a a part of that reality
curation nooses actual nooses like real
nooses have been used for thousands of
years for different applications but yes
often to perform executions many
thousands of people or millions
of all different races have died that
way through the course of human history
many of them have been convicted
criminals in some cases they are
unjustly lynched by violent mobs but
whoever decided that the noose this this
like universal object is a symbol of
special significance to black people
when when did that start
well the media decided that
they decided it some time ago and and
they've now turned it into a reality
through one hoax after another
they've been so successful in
constructing this reality that even
people on the right who are skeptical of
the individual noose hoaxes still don't
stop to question why we're pretending
that the noose is a racist symbol in the
first place
that's the power of the false reality
that the left has constructed
and which permeates and intrudes into
the lives of people who would otherwise
know better
so it's a very unique situation in
modern times they've always they've
always been liars and propagandists in
the world but never with such immediate
and all-encompassing access to so many
people
and so with this ability to
fundamentally reshape how we look at the
world
which is all the more reason to remain
vigilant and skeptical and if we stand
in the truth
to stand there stubbornly
at least as stubborn as the liars are
with their lies well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content